last night's RNC speech from Botox
vampire Melania Trump was monumentally
important if Donald Trump is elected
she'd be America's first lady and
possibly planet Earth's final lady
unfortunately for her diligent
Internet's loose discovered that she
flat-out ripped off of Michelle Obama's
speech take a look your word is your
bond to know that only limits are the
height of your Chi but is the rich of
your grooms and your willingness to work
hard for them yeah actually we didn't
show the whole thing Melania Trump
speech does divert at the end where she
goes blah blah one the one monotone
trophy wife
she's the third she's also inexplicably
cribbed a popular internet meme
comedians did she a rick roll everyone
me tell a heart-wrenching tale about two
girls forced to share one cup see refer
to life in small-town Slovenia as oppa
Gangnam style Dave Holmes I she seems
like a Rick roller let's blend down
today let's find out
you will never ever
here's the thing yeah by the way we do
have to think we do have to thank swag
blog who made this video and put that
all together yeah what we're gonna
here's the thing history has proven that
he will run around and desert you